[موسيقى]
كانت هناك اتصالات منذ اليوم الاول للحرب
وما زال التواصل مستمرا الاستخبارات
والدوائر العسكريه ووزارات الخارجيه
واطراف ثالثه كلها ضالعه في الاتصال ايضا
مسؤولون سابقون هناك اتصالات يوميه وفي
بعض الاحيان عبر وساطات من اطراف ثالثه
كانت هناك دوما مناقشات واحد علاماتها
تبادل والسجناء والذي لا يحدث من فراغ
والذي لعب فيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دور الرئيسي لانجاحه نعم كانت هناك
مناقشات وستستمر وهي احد اسباب استمرار
الرحلات الجويه من اسطنبول الى موسكو عبر
الخطوط التركيه التي تسير ما لا يقل عن
اربع رحلات يوميه بسبب ان هناك اطراف تقوم
بالرحله ذهابا وعوده يوميا بين موسكو
[موسيقى]
اتوقع لذلك ان يبدا في الحدوث انطلاقا من
سبتمبر والذي ستكون فيه صوره اوضح بما
يجعلنا نتوقع ما سيحدث بين سبتمبر وديسمبر
ورجح ان يكون الهجوم الاوكراني ناجحا في
بعض المناطق وفشلا في اخرى ولن يكون لذلك
علاقه بكفاءه الاوكرانيين والروس وانما
بحجم الاشخاص الذين سيمكن للاتحاد الروسي
تجنيدهم ضمن قواته وحجم العتاد الذي سيكون
بحوزتها اذا قرر المسؤولون استخدامه ومن
الجانب الاوكراني نعم لديهم قوات ملتزمه
ولكنها ليست بالحجم الملائم كما لديهم
تجهيزات ولكن هناك نوع من الحدود له فقد
دابوا خلال الشهرين الماضيين على تكرار
انهم يحتكمون على 98% مما يحتاجون لبدي
هجومهم
[موسيقى]